physicists have this way of simplifying
a science problem so you're trained to
kind of look at the messy complex
situation and abstract it a little bit
simplify throw away details sometimes
it's too many details sometimes you
don't find out and talk to the fact
whether you've thrown away too much but
the idea is to kind of retain the the
essence or the complexity of the
phenomenon you're trying to understand
but to simplify it in such a way that
you make a mathematical model that can
be analyzed mathematically so the key
what a good physicist does is they find
that sweet spot right where they where
they have just enough detail that they
are truly capturing the interesting
stuff but on the other hand that it's
simple enough that you can actually
analyze the model mathematically and so
that means not only that you can do
computer simulations or or that kind of
analysis but also that you can do
calculations and maybe prove some
theorems and when you have a model
that's simple like that where you can
study it mathematically you can gain
insights and then you learn things and
you can bring that back to the original
problem and I think that that kind of
skill is very valuable not just in
physics but also in biology and
neuroscience and other sciences and it's
really the contribution that someone
with the theoretical physics training
can do well it's interesting actually
neuroscience has people from all over
who have come and started working on on
problems without the brain and many of
them are theoretical physicist by
training and they bring that they bring
that quality of trying to abstract and
simplify in a way that makes a problem
mathematically tractable and I think
it's it's you know made a very important
contribution to the field and will
continue to do so